aquí tenemos un campo magnético ve este
campo magnético va hacia afuera está
apuntando hacia afuera de la pantalla
además aquí tenemos un alambre en color
amarillo sobre el cual hay una carga q y
vamos a pensar vamos a pensar que hay
sólo una pequeña porción de este alambre
que está siendo afectada por el campo
magnético y que esa está acotada en una
región así y que está separada por una
distancia l muy bien entonces está
separado a una distancia l tenemos un
campo magnético hacia afuera y tenemos
una carga q entonces qué va a suceder
bueno pues si la carga es estacionaria
no va a pasar nada verdad cómo le
hacemos para ver que no pasa nada pues
recordamos la primer fórmula que vimos
hace algunos vídeos que nos dice que la
fuerza que ejerce el campo magnético en
una carga es igual a la carga
multiplicada por el producto cruz de la
velocidad con el campo magnético
entonces qué pasa en magnitudes si
sacamos magnitudes a ambos lados
tenemos que la magnitud de la fuerza es
igual a que este ya era un escalar por
la magnitud de la velocidad por la
magnitud del campo multiplicada por el
seno de teta éste s no detecta otra vez
más anda y de la tos o porque como el
alambre está en el plano de la pantalla
y como el campo magnético es
perpendicular ese plano entonces este
seno de teta va a ser un seno de 90
grados entonces nada más es un 1 no nos
preocupamos mucho por él pero pero como
te decía si así la carga no está en
movimiento entonces su velocidad va a
ser cero y entonces la magnitud va a ser
cero porque aquí tendríamos un cero
entonces no pasaría nada interesante
pero vamos a realizar un experimento
vamos a empezar a mover este alambre
hacia el lado izquierdo con una cierta
velocidad para entonces se mueve vaya
con una cierta velocidad ve vamos a
ponerle que se mueve para allá con una
cierta velocidad ve muy bien entonces
ahora sí ya van a pasar cosas
interesantes de verdad ahora si la carga
ya va a estar en movimiento y vamos a
ver qué nos dice esta fórmula
entonces en esta fórmula ya tendríamos
aquí pues una magnitud que no es cero
aquí un 1 aquí un campo magnético que
vamos a suponer que tiene magnitud
distinta de cero entonces ahora sí va a
haber una fuerza actuando sobre la carga
cuál va a ser esta fuerza y hacia dónde
va a ser bueno la magnitud ya la tenemos
y para encontrar la dirección tenemos
que utilizar la regla de la mano derecha
creo que esta regla de la mano derecha
está fácil de dibujar porque a ver el
primer término es el dedo índice que
tiene que apuntar hacia la izquierda es
la velocidad el segundo término es el
dedo medio que tiene que apuntar hacia
donde apunte el campo magnético apunta
hacia afuera de la pantalla
si quieres le pongo el puntito por aquí
tenemos los otros dedos y entonces
entonces la fuerza va hacia dónde apunta
el pulgar la masa que acabo de dibujar
los otros dedos y el pulgar viene por
acá
más o menos algo así entonces la fuerza
la fuerza que ejerce el campo
electromagnético sobre la carga va hacia
arriba eso está padre verdad esta fuerza
está haciendo que la carga ahora se
mueva hacia arriba pero imagínate qué
sucedería si tenemos mucha si tuviéramos
muchas cargas aquí en este alambre pues
entonces tengamos muchas cargas
moviéndose sobre el alambre y qué es eso
pues eso justo es una corriente y bueno
dependiendo de cuántas cargas tengamos
va a ser la la magnitud de esa corriente
va pero bueno entonces esto está padre
lo que nos dice es que al mover un
alambre por un campo magnético o bueno
también funciona si movemos el campo
magnético verdad y dejamos final el
alambre pero bueno si si si movemos el
alambre lo que estamos haciendo es
generar una corriente una corriente aquí
eso está súper padre porque así es como
funcionan los generadores eléctricos
después vamos a ver más vídeos de eso
pero la idea general es que con vapor o
con carbón o con energía nuclear o con
viento de varias formas lo que podemos
hacer es moverse
varas y con eso podemos generar
electricidad entonces eso está súper
padre pero bueno ahí te va una pregunta
si esta partícula empieza aquí justo en
el momento en el cual el campo empieza a
hacer efecto en este caso de acá
entonces cuál sería el trabajo que
realiza el campo magnético sobre esta
carga bueno pues vamos a acordarnos como
le hacíamos para calcular el trabajo el
trabajo vamos a ponerle w
el trabajo w está dado y al multiplicar
la fuerza por la distancia hay que ser
un poco cuidadosos con las direcciones
verdad de la dirección de la fuerza y la
distancia porque esto podría ser un
vector pero ahorita nada más lo voy a
poner así para que no quede demasiado
complicado entonces utilizando esta
información vamos a combinar estas dos
fórmulas vale entonces que nos queda nos
quedaría que el trabajo es igual a voy a
poner primero esta parte a la magnitud
de la carga multiplicada por voy a dejar
habitar un espacio fijo por acá por el
producto cruz de la velocidad con el
campo magnético
y aquí lo que tengo que poner es la
distancia que recorre la carga pero esta
distancia ya le pusimos un nombre se
llama l entonces aquí voy a poner el
vale entonces es q por l por el producto
cruz debe con be de la velocidad con el
campo magnético bueno entonces ahora qué
sucede si dividimos entre carga de ambos
lados
tendríamos que doble uno entre q es
igual a
este ya lo pasamos dividiendo a l por b
cruz el campo magnético vale esto está
padre porque lo que nos dice es el
trabajo que se hace sobre cada una de
estas cargas y más aún también está
padre porque ven que es jules sobre
coloms o sea que es trabajo sobre carga
pues eso justo es voltaje verdad
jules no voy a poner aquí yo
wills sobre colom conlon
son volts volts entonces esto está re
bueno lo que nos está diciendo es que
esta carga se mueve como si hubiera un
voltaje como si hubiera una diferencia
de potencial en este alambre de acá
pensando en que de este lado tenemos
tenemos el lado positivo y el lado
negativo porque estamos yendo hacia
arriba verdad hacia arriba está yendo a
la fuerza entonces esto está padrísimo
hay como una diferencia de potencial
percibida percibida así como entre
comillas porque osea si vivieras en el
alambre y no supieras que se está
moviendo entonces pensarías que hay una
diferencia de potencial pero bueno
aunque es básicamente lo mismo a la
gente le gusta darle un nombre especial
a esta esta diferencia de potencial y se
le conoce como fuerza electromotriz
déjalo escribo por acá fuerza
electromotriz va fuerza electromotriz
pero bueno o sea nada más es porque
estamos dentro de este contexto pero al
final de cuentas es lo mismo sigue
siendo trabaja sobre cargas y trabajó
sobre carga sigue siendo en jules sobre
colom entonces sigue siendo volts es
simplemente un voltaje o bien una
diferencia de potencial
simplemente como viene de este contexto
en el cual hay como una fuerza mágica de
un campo magnético actuando entonces se
le da el nombre especial de fuerza
electromotriz entonces resumiendo esto
tenemos que que la fuerza electromotriz
que la fuerza electromotriz es igual a
la longitud por el producto cruz del
voltaje con el campo magnético bueno
para que las cosas no queden así tan
abstractas vamos a poner algunos
numeritos para hacer un problema va
entonces déjame poner que la magnitud de
este campo la magnitud de este campo es
de dos teclas vamos a pensar que la
velocidad con la cual nos estamos
moviendo es de no sé vamos a ponerle
tres metros sobre segundo
tres metros sobre segundo vamos a poner
que esta longitud es de 12 metros vamos
a ponerle 12 metros y creo que es todo
bueno mira vamos a calcular la corriente
que va a pasar por el alambre entonces
para eso vamos a necesitar saber acerca
de una resistencia por aquí entonces
vamos a poner una resistencia
ahí está la resistencia y esa
resistencia va a ser de 6 oms 6 oms
ok creo que ya tenemos todo lo necesario
con esto va a ser un poco más
entretenido el problema entonces vamos a
empezar calculando la fuerza
electromotriz va entonces la fuerza
electromotriz la fuerza electromotriz en
magnitud va a ser igual a l l que es 12
metros 12 multiplicada por la velocidad
la velocidad es de 33 metros
multiplicada por por el la magnitud del
campo magnético que es 2 esto es la
magnitud pero bueno todo funciona bien
por por esta razón el seno de teta que
es 90 grados entonces podemos nada más
múltiple
a todos estos números y estoy acá que
quedamos que eran pues todo estaba en
volts entonces estos son volts y esto
cuánto es pues a ver 12 por 336 por 2
son 72 72 volts muy bien pero nosotros
queremos encontrar la corriente va pero
tenemos ya el voltaje y tenemos la
resistencia entonces para terminar nos
acordamos de nos acordamos de nuestra
fórmula que relacionaba todas estas
variables que dice que dice que el
voltaje lo voy a poner por acá que el
voltaje es igual a la corriente por la
resistencia y por lo tanto la corriente
es igual a pasamos la r dividiendo
dividimos entre r de ambos lados nos
queda que que la corriente es igual al
voltaje entre la resistencia entonces ya
nada más terminamos de este lado de esta
forma tenemos que la corriente es igual
a 72 volts dividido entre la resistencia
que son 6 oms
homs entonces nos queda 72 entre 6 que
es igual a 12 12 amper muy bien entonces
ya terminamos el problema y concluimos
que la corriente causada por el campo
magnético dado que movimos este este
alambre con una velocidad dada es de 12
am persa